[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you
thank
you
thank you
my friends it's great to be with you
here in Birmingham it's fantastic to see
the cranes across the skyline building
new buildings
the busy trams coursing down the streets
and the bull standing proudly at the
heart of Birmingham
my friends this is what a city with a
Tory mayor looks like
it's positive it's enterprising it's
successful and Andy street is a human
Dynamo delivering
with Birmingham
and our tea side mayor Ben Houchin is
also delivering new jobs and investment
this is what modern conservatism looks
like let's get Tori Mayers elected in
London in Manchester in West Yorkshire
and right across our great country
We Gather at a vital time for the United
Kingdom
these are stormy days
together we've mourned the death of
Queen Elizabeth II The Rock on which
modern Britain was built
we're now in a new era
under King Charles III
we're dealing with the global economic
crisis caused by covid and by Putin's
appalling war in Ukraine
in these tough times we need to step up
I'm determined to get Britain moving to
get us through the Tempest and to put us
on a stronger footing as a nation
I'm driven in this Mission by my firm
belief in the British people
I believe that you know best how to
spend your own money to get on in life
and to realize your ambitions
my friends that is what conservatism is
about
it's a belief in Freedom in Fair Play
and the great potential of the British
people
so I'm not going to tell you what to do
or what to think or how to live your
life
I'm not interested in how many two for
one offers you buy at the supermarket or
how you spend your spare time or in
virtue signaling
I'm not interested in just talking about
things but actually in doing things
what I'm interested in is your hopes and
fears that you feel every day
can you get a good job locally
is it safe to walk down the High Street
late at night can you get a doctor's
appointment
I know how you feel because I have the
same hopes and fears
I want what you want
I've fought to get where I am today
I fought to get jobs
to get pay Rises and get on the housing
ladder
I've juggled my career with raising two
wonderful daughters
I know how it feels to have your
potential dismissed by those who think
they know better
I remember as a young girl being
presented on a plane with a junior air
hostess badge
Meanwhile my brothers were given Junior
pilot badges
it wasn't the only time in my life
that I've been treated differently for
being female or for not fitting in
it made me angry and it made me
determined determined to change things
so other people didn't feel the same way
I remember growing up in Leeds
where I saw too many children being let
down
let down by low expectations let down by
a labor Council who were more interested
in political correctness than they were
in school standards
but I was lucky to have been brought up
in a family that cared about education
they taught me the value of hard work
and Enterprise
and I stand here today as the first
prime minister of our country to have
gone to a comprehensive School
stop that taught me two things one is
that we have huge Talent across our
country and two that we're not making
enough of it
this is a great country I'm so proud of
who we are and what we stand for but I
know that we can do better and I know
that we must do better and that's why I
entered politics
I want to live in a country where hard
work's rewarded where women can walk
home safely at night and where our
children have a better future
to deliver this we need to get Britain
moving we cannot have any more drift and
delay at this vital time
let's remember where we were
when I entered Downing Street
average energy bills were predicted to
soar above 6 000 pounds a year
we Face the highest tax burden that our
country had had for 70 years
and we were told that we could do
nothing about it
I didn't accept that things had to be
that way I knew that in action would be
unconscionable
families would have been unable to heat
their homes
businesses would have gone bust
jobs would have been lost
and we would have worse public services
including the NHS I couldn't allow this
to happen
I refused to consign our great country
to decline
and that's why I promised on entering
Downing Street to act
oh my God
[Applause]
let's get them removed
[Applause]
come on
[Music]
now
thank you thank you thank you
now later on in my speech my friends I'm
going to talk about the anti-growth
Coalition but I think I think I think
they arrived in the hall a bit too early
uh they were meant to they were meant to
come later on so we'll uh we'll we'll
get on to them
uh we'll get on to them we'll get on to
them in a few minutes
but what we did is we acted we made sure
that the typical household Energy bill
shouldn't be more than around 2 500
pounds a year this winter and next we
followed up with a major action to
support businesses over the winter we're
determined to Shield people from
astronomically High bills
so much so that we are doing more in
this country to protect people from the
energy crisis than any other country in
Europe
our response to the energy crisis was
the biggest part of our midi budget it
was the biggest part for a good reason
because we had to do it but it's not the
only challenge we face
for too long our economy hasn't grown as
strongly as it should have done
I know what it's like to live somewhere
that isn't feeling the benefits of
economic growth
I grew up in Paisley and in Leeds in the
80s and 90s
I've seen the boarded up shops
I've seen people left with no hope
turning to drugs
I've seen families struggling to put
food on the table
low growth isn't just numbers on a
spreadsheet low growth means lower wages
fewer opportunities and less money to
spend on the things that make life
better
it means our country falling behind
other countries including those who
threaten our way of life
and it means the parts of our country
that I really care about falling even
further behind
that is why we must level up our country
in a conservative way ensuring
everywhere everyone can get on
foreign
it's wrong to invest only in the places
that are thriving as economic models
often have it we need to fund the
furthest behind first
and for too long the political debate
has been dominated by the argument about
how we distribute a limited economic pie
instead we need to grow the pie so that
everyone gets a bigger slice
that is why I'm determined to take a new
approach and break us out of this High
tax low growth cycle and that's what our
plan is about it's about getting the
economy growing and rebuilding Britain
through reform
the scale of this challenge is immense
war in Europe for the first time in a
generation
a more uncertain world in the aftermath
of covert and a global economic crisis
that is why in Britain we need to do
things differently we need to step up
as the last few weeks have shown it will
be difficult whenever there's change
there is disruption and not everybody
will be in favor of change
but everyone will benefit from the
results a growing economy and a better
future
thank you
that is what we have a clear plan to
deliver
I have three priorities for our economy
growth
growth and growth
gross means more money in people's
pockets it means businesses creating new
jobs growth means people feel can feel
secure and they can plan for their
future fundamentally growth helps people
fulfill their hopes and their dreams and
that's why our Dynamic new Chancellor
and I will be taking action in three
areas
first of all we will lower
first of all we will lower our tax
burden
over the summer we had a robust debate
and the conservative party will always
be the party of low taxes
cutting taxes is the right thing to do
morally and economically morally because
the state doesn't spend its own money it
spends the people's money
economically because if people keep more
of their own money they're inspired to
do more of what they do best that's what
grows the economy
when the government plays too big a role
people feel smaller high taxes mean you
feel it's less worthwhile working that
extra hour going for a better job or
setting you up your own business that's
my friends is why we are cutting taxes
we've already cut stamp Duty helping
people on the housing ladder especially
first-time buyers we're reversing the
increase in National Insurance from next
month and we're keeping corporation tax
at 19 the lowest in the G20 we're also
helping 31 million working people by
cutting the basic rate of income tax
we need to be internationally
competitive with all our tax rates
attracting the best talent
cutting taxes helps us face the global
economic crisis putting up a sign that
Britain is open for business
the fact is that the abolition of the
45p tax rate became a distraction from
the major parts of our growth plan that
is why we're no longer proceeding with
it I get it and I have listened
secondly we will keep an iron grip on
the nation's finances I believe in
fiscal responsibility I believe in
getting value for the taxpayer I believe
in sound money and a lean State I
remember my shock opening my first
paycheck to see how much money the tax
man had taken out
I know this feeling is replicated across
the country
and that's why we must always be careful
with taxpayers money
it's why this government will always be
fiscally responsible
we are in extraordinary times it would
have been wrong not to have proceeded
rapidly with our energy and tax plan
I am clear we cannot pave the way to
sustainable economic growth without
fiscal responsibility so we will bring
down debt as a proportion of our
national income
we are seeing Rising interest rates
worldwide in the wake of Putin's war and
covert the Federal Reserve has been
hiking rates in America and has signaled
more Rises to come inflation is high
across the world's major economies we
will do what we can as a government to
support homeowners such as cutting stamp
duty but it's right that interest rates
are independently set by the bank of
England and that politicians do not
decide on this
the chancellor and the governor will
keep closely coordinating our monetary
and fiscal policy and the chancellor and
I are in complete lockstep on this
thirdly we will drive economic reforms
to build our country for a new era we're
taking a new approach based on what's
worked before
previously we faced barriers to growth
like militant unions nationalized
Industries and outdated City regulation
now we must break down the barriers to
growth built up in our system over
decades
decisions take too long burdens on
businesses are too high infrastructure
projects get delayed for years and years
and years
as a result we've seen economic growth
choked off
houses haven't been built where they are
needed and wanted and we've become a
verse as a nation to doing things
differently
I love business I love Enterprise I love
people who take responsibility start
their own businesses and invest
they generate profits they create new
jobs and they power our success and I
want to see more of that that's why we
will back business to the hilt we're
cutting taxes and we're simplifying red
tape to help businesses realize their
Ambitions and this is what our new
investment zones will do helping us
level up across the country we're going
to be inspired by the great hubs of
Industry like bournville here in the
West Midlands and that's what zones in
places like here and around the country
will deliver we want to create the zones
in England Scotland Wales and Northern
Ireland now is the time to harness the
power of free enterprise to transform
our country ensure that our greatest
days lie ahead
this is the United Kingdom at its best
working together and getting our economy
growing and we will face down the
separatists who threaten to pull our
part our precious Union or family
next year we will host the global
investment Summit
this will show the world's top investors
there's nowhere better to invest in the
UK and we're seizing the Newfound
freedoms outside the European Union
We're the Party who got brexit done and
we will realize on the promise of brexit
we're building an economy which makes
the most of the huge opportunities
brexit offers by the end of the year all
EU red tape will be consigned to history
foreign
we will ensure that regulation is
pro-business and progress
leaving the EU gives us the chance to do
things differently and we need more of
that
that's why over the coming weeks my team
of ministers will set out more about
what we're going to do to get Britain
moving we'll make it easier to build
homes to afford child care and to get
super fast Broadband we'll help you set
up your own business and get a mobile
phone signal wherever you are in the
country
thank you
we're in tough times
but I want you to know that day in day
out I'm thinking about how we get this
country moving I'm working flat out to
make sure people can get through this
crisis so let me be clear we have your
back
that is why the government took decisive
action to tackle the energy crisis it's
why we're pushing ahead with our plan
for growth economic growth makes life
better and easier for everyone and it
will level up our country
I know this is what people want to see
economic growth will mean that we can
afford great public services such as
schools the police and the NHS
our fantastic Deputy Prime Minister and
health secretary will deliver for
patients so they can expect a GP
appointment within two weeks
she will ensure that those who need
Urgent Care will be seen on the same day
and she will get ambulances out there
faster and she will improve a e
and she will bust the covert batlog
it's not all that's not all and she will
bolster social care so everyone gets the
care they need
thank you
we are working to put this country on
the path to long-term success
that means ensuring we are safe and
secure
one of the reasons we're facing This
Global crisis is because collectively
the West did not do enough
we became complacent
we didn't spend enough on defense
we became too dependent on authoritarian
regimes for cheap goods and cheap energy
and we did not stand up to Russia early
enough
we will make sure this never happens
again
so we are taking decisive action to
reinforce our energy security we're
opening more gas fields in the North Sea
and delivering more Renewables and
nuclear energy this is how we will
protect the Great British environment
deliver on our commitment to Net Zero
and Tackle climate change
thank you
we're also taking decisive action by
strengthening our borders and beefing up
our border force and expanding the
Rwanda scheme our brilliant New Home
Secretary will be bringing forward
legislation to make sure that no
European judge can overrule us
and while while she is acting meanwhile
the labor party has absolutely no plan
to tackle illegal immigration
but my friends we cannot have security
at home without security abroad that's
why our tough foreign and defense
secretaries are on updating the
integrated review to make sure we can
face down these threats
it's why we're increasing defense
spending to three percent of GDP by the
end of the decade
this will ensure that our armed forces
are ready to tackle new and emerging
threats
we're working with our friends and
allies to support Ukraine in the face of
Putin's brutal War the brave Ukrainian
people
the brave Ukrainian people aren't just
fighting for their security but for all
our security this is a fight for freedom
and democracy around the world
Putin's illegal annexation of Ukrainian
territory is just the latest act in his
campaign to subvert democracy and
violate international law
we should not give in to those who want
to deal which trades away Ukrainian land
they are proposing to pay in Ukrainian
lives for the illusion of peace
we will stand with our Ukrainian friends
however long it takes Ukraine can win
Ukraine must win and Ukraine will win
foreign
the people of Ukraine will welcome our
solidarity with them at this very very
difficult time
to take on Russia another authoritarian
regimes free democracies need strong
economies
economic growth makes us strong at home
and strong abroad and we need an
economically sound and secure United
Kingdom
and that will mean challenging those who
try to stop growth I will not allow the
anti-growth coalition to hold us back
labor the lib Dems the SMP
the militant unions the vested interests
dressed up as think tanks the Talking
Heads the brexit deniers extinction
rebellion and some of the people we had
in the hall earlier
the fact is
they prefer protesting to doing
they prefer talking on Twitter to taking
tough decisions they taxi from North
London townhouses to the BBC Studio to
dismiss anyone challenging the status
quo
from broadcast to podcast they pedal the
same old answers
it's always more taxes more regulation
and more meddling
wrong wrong
we see we see the anti-growth Coalition
at work across our country
wants to put extra taxes on the
companies we need to invest in our
energy security
and his sticking plaster solution will
only last six months he has no long-term
plan and no vision for Britain
Mark Drakeford in Wales is canceling
Road building projects and refusing to
build the M4 relief Road
Nicholas sturgeon won't build new
nuclear power stations to solve the
energy crisis in Scotland
have these people ever seen a tax rise
they don't like
or or an industry they don't want to
control
they don't understand the British people
they don't understand aspiration they
are prepared to leave our towns and
cities facing decline
foreign
does the anti-growth Coalition have any
idea who pays their wages
it's it's the people who make things in
factories across our country it's the
people who get up at the crack of dorm
to go to work it's the commuters who get
trains into towns and cities across our
country I'm thinking of the white van
drivers the hairdressers the plumbers
the accountants the I.T workers and
millions of others up and down the UK
foreign
Coalition just doesn't get it
it's because they don't face the same
challenges as normal working people
these enemies of Enterprise don't know
the frustration you feel to see your
road blocked by protesters or your
trains off due to a strike
in fact their friends on the hard left
tend to be the ones behind the
disruption
the anti-growth Coalition think that
people who stick themselves to trains
roads and buildings are heroes
I say the real heroes are the people who
go out to work take responsibility and
aspire to a better life for themselves
and their families
and I am on their side
we will build roads rail energy and
Broadband quicker we will be proudly
pro-growth Pro aspiration and
pro-enterprise that is how we will Forge
ahead on our long-term path to National
success
in this new era we're taking a new
approach
my friends we're focused on boosting
growth and opportunity across our
country
this Mission will be difficult
but it is necessary
we have no alternative if we want to get
our economy moving again
I'm ready to make the hard choices
you can trust me to do what it takes
the status quo is not an option
that is why we can't give in to the
voices of decline we can't give in to
those who say Britain can't go faster we
can't give in to those who say we can't
do better we must stay the course
we're the only party with a clear plan
to get Britain moving we are the only
party with the determination to deliver
together we can unleash the full
potential of our great country that is
how we will build a New Britain for a
new era
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
there we are the end of the first speech
from Liz truss as a prime minister she
said she had the same hopes as many of
the people watching her speech this
afternoon this morning I should say she
was interrupted by a Greenpeace
demonstration she dealt with that very
well actually and they were removed from
the hall and she continued on mentioning
growth some 27 times perhaps a little
slip up when she talked about being the
first prime minister to go to a
comprehensive school and Sam's with me
I'm not sure that's true Sam Gordon
Brown We Believe oh Jacob Reese smorg
actually bear with me one second with
Ali Ali
hello yes we've got Jacob Breeze smog
how was that for you I mean it's a
pretty divided party right now did she
do enough I don't think we are divided I
think the support for that speech was
overwhelming she said how clear
conservative policies she is pro-growth
and we have helped people with their
energy bills we have shown that we are a
tax cutting government that believes
people spend their own money better than
the state spends it for them this was a
really proper conservative speech which
will be very unified you said the
parties is best when it works together I
mean it's not working together you
cannot say this week has gone to plan
has it well we're clearly working on a
plan for growth for the economy what
does that mean that means that people's
money goes further that it's easier for
them to buy the goods that they need
that their pay will go up that and it
will because of the cutting National
Insurance and The Cutting income tax
people have more money in their pockets
they will have a better standard of
living that's what it's all about as
Disraeli used to put it some time ago
it's about improving the condition of
the people that's what the conservative
governments have always hoped to do
reports this morning that that you want
to see benefits rise in line with
inflation that is at odds with the hints
coming from number 10. are you adult
with the Prime Minister I'm never at
odds with the Prime Minister either this
one or the previous one
um but as far as I'm aware the decision
hasn't been made and there's a legal
process a stature instrument has to be
laid I think the social safe work and
pensions has certain Authority in this
area
but governments discuss decisions before
they're made and then they get made and
then they get supported that's the
normal process of government okay what's
the PM going to do now to heal divisions
with the back benches it's pretty clear
that people are angry that that is
something she needs to do well I'm not
sure is that clear that people are angry
there are always some moaning minis look
I used to do this at party conferences
and go around and say that I think
things should be done differently when I
was on the back benches that's what
backbenchers do so you don't think she
needs to do anything to heal divisions
on the back benches what we need is
exactly what's set out good conservative
policies and that's what she's offering
and look at the response she got
absolutely brilliant and class did she's
still alive from kirst armor some
reports that she said growth growth
gross those are three priorities that's
something that kirstalmer said a couple
years ago in a speech oh lord well I
haven't studied secure speeches
carefully enough this has been most
remiss of me to work out every phrase
that he has ever used okay thank you so
much Jacob what do you think well there
you go I mean the atmosphere in here I
have to say was good they were several
standing ovations there were of course
though protesters two that came in
stopped the speech but obviously it's
not just this whole that Liz truss needs
to win over to people Beyond this Hall
and it has been whatever Jacob riesmorg
says an extraordinary few days and
extraordinary context we've seen cabinet
splits inconsistent messages coming out
of cabinet and privately ministers and
back Ventures have been unhappy with not
just the 45 P U-turn but the way things
have been handled more broadly the way
that she has tried to communicate her
message and the way that she's tried to
reach out to back benches that will be
the big challenge for Liz truss it was a
speech that was slightly longer than we
expected was it enough to heal divisions
I think that definitely remains to be
seen
and indeed Samuel thoughts a New Britain
for a new era what we got was Liz
truss's vision for her Premiership today
and I think what you on uh you've got a
very clear sense of what she's going to
talk about and campaign on for months
growth growth growth whether or not it
was what Kirsten said uh labor say that
he said it in a speech over the summer
she made her argument why that was the
most important priority for the country
said look you need that growth in order
to pay for public services low taxes was
her is her other priority she said look
allowing people to keep more of their
money will motivate them to work and
you've got the sort of central political
argument that we're going to be hearing
I think for weeks and months to come
this is the business of the anti-growth
Coalition taking on figures be they in
the different nations of different
regions or in the labor party or in the
unions uh nimby's holding back growth
and I think that uh was uh so we've got
a central argument for Liz truss's
Premiership there were moments of
political Flair yeah I just wanted if we
could just deal with it and then move on
to that ratifying the channel
particularly so one of the big jobs one
of the big jobs is to reassure the
market uh interesting that the pound
against the dollar top left-hand Corner
uh is uh stable and I think that that
was a consequence of three things that
she did in that speech she confirmed
quasi quality in place it's been a rough
week for him but she made it clear he
was staying as Chancellor as she talked
about iron fiscal discipline uh and made
clear that he would be working so I was
working very closely with the bank of
England so that wasn't a message to
voters that wasn't a message to the
conservative party in the hall that was
a message to the market and people who
decide really how much we're all gonna
be paying on our mortgages yeah